يتم إرسال جرعات أكثر من لقاح جدري القردة
إلى الدول التي تتعامل
مع تدفق الفيروس من أجل
تعزيز استجابتها وتحت
ضغط من الولايات ، تقوم إدارة بيدن
بإطلاق
الجرعات الإضافية من اللقاح من
المخزون الوطني الاستراتيجي  إلى جانب المزيد من الاختبارات
، تم انتقاد خطة التوزيع الحالية
بسبب نطاقها المحدود
مع اللقاحات المتاحة فقط لأولئك الذين
لديهم تعرض معروف بموجب الخطة الجديدة
للقاحات ، وسيتم تخصيص الاختبارات
للولايات بناءً على معدل الحالة الذي يركز على
الرجال الذين يمارسون الجنس مع الرجال و  أكد
شركاؤهم المعروفون جنبًا إلى جنب مع أي شخص
يعتقد أنهم قد تعرضوا مؤخرًا من
خلال
شريك مجهول ، أكدت الولايات المتحدة أكثر من 350
حالة حتى الآن بينما يتوقع الخبراء أن
الفيروس أكثر انتشارًا مما
يشير عدد الحالات الحالي إلى أنهم لا
يسمونه أزمة بعد.  أعتقد أنه
سيكون من
الخطر تصنيفها على أنها منخفضة أو
مرتفعة
بالنظر إلى الأرقام التي لن أقولها
الآن في هذا الصدد  نقطة معينة تشير إلى
أنه اقتباس عالي الخطورة ولكن الأرقام قد
تزداد مما يعني أنه علينا
توخي الحذر والاهتمام
بالدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا ماري مالوني